[Music]
the reality is the real story here is
not that this case isn't gonna fizzle
it's gonna blow up on them the real
question is what we talked about before
there's a lot more to what they did that
nobody knows about yet I know a lot more
to the obstruction of justice to the
collusion to the fate dusty I know I end
up being sealed back in after he was
completely discredited and then feed it
to Muller yeah and Muller is gonna have
a lot to answer for president Trump's
attorney Rudy Giuliani last night right
here on this program describing how
Muller's case is quote going to blow up
in the special councils face somebody's
been saying that for a little while the
host to see our TVs Levin TV right here
Sunday night 10:00 Eastern the number
one show on Sunday night on cable news
it's the great one Mark Levin let me let
you pick up from here but you also been
saying things that I've been paying very
close attention to the Constitution of
the United States is on the president's
side president ought not be speaking to
the people that are running this
witch-hunt
take it from there first of all Robert
Muller is a greater threat to this
Republic in the Constitution than
anything Vladimir Putin did during the
campaign and I'm no fan of Latin he's
threatening to take down a president the
United States now let's walk through
this quickly the president is not a
witness to any crime how do we know that
because we don't know what crime they're
even talking about so he doesn't need to
be questioned as a witness President did
not commit a crime what crime did he
commit so he's not a target he doesn't
need to be questioned about that
according to the Department of Justice
president can't be indicted a president
cannot be questioned by a subordinate
like mr. Muller about his prerogatives
as president that is the firing of a
subordinate like mr. Comey so what
questions exactly does mr. Muller have
talking to you mr. Muller exactly what
questions that you have will you seek to
turn this country upside down and
disenfranchise the over 60 million
people who voted for this president of
the United States
you are a plaything of the media you're
a plaything
the Democrats you're a plaything of
people within the Obama administration
who sought from day one to take this
president down now the President of the
United States is not an ordinary citizen
he must protect the Constitution he has
to protect the office of the presidency
he has to protect the president's
prerogatives he has to protect
separation of powers that's what this
president is doing against this rogue
prosecutor it is Trump who has the white
hat
it is Muller who has the black hat and
the president's lawyers should this go
to court are going to have a fantastic
opportunity to expose mr. Muller to
question mr. Muller to question where
does he have his constitutional power
under the appointments clause to
question him about whether he thinks a
president can be indicted even though
the Department of Justice says no to
question him to explain why despite
public report public report public
report about the FBI the CIA the Pfizer
record the dossier Hillary Clinton's
association with Russians we have
Russians everywhere but not with Trump
there with Hillary Clinton there with a
fusion GPS that way there was Bruce or
there was this is important stay on that
there are there are everywhere
Russian lies sold to FISA Court judges a
fraud committed on the on the court not
once mark four times slice spreads
obviously to the American people that
sounds like the former Soviet Union Mark
Levin so the question is if mr. Muller
is such a great prosecutor why is he
blind as a bat to all this that's taking
place in this country you want to pursue
Russia mr. mr. Muller I can find your
first-year law student who can show you
what to pursue the fact of the matter is
ladies and gentlemen of the court
President wasn't a witness to a crime he
wasn't surrounded by Russians president
didn't commit a crime the president
cannot be indicted so as I keep saying
on this program mr. Muller
you can leave the room and don't let the
door hit you in the ass on the way out
we'll see you in court and if they go to
court then it is an opportunity for the
president's lawyers to expose exactly
what's going on here what should they
know
miss Jordan focus on that well I think
what they should do is not only ask the
court to explain what authority mr.
Muller has to do what he's doing
given the ridiculous appointment that he
received that is so broad is
preposterous and if you can't indict a
sitting president you better have a damn
good reason I want to sit down with him
and questioning them these questions if
they're to be asked at all have to be
very very narrow I wouldn't sit down
with him and and answer any question the
fact of the matter is there is no
obstruction of justice he wasn't a
witness to a crime he didn't commit a
crime
he can't be indicted mr. Muller can't
questioning him about presidential
prerogatives so what the hell is the
point of this whole thing other than to
set him up for impeachment because the
Democrats and the media want to remove a
president who was elected by over 60
million people to disenfranchise all of
us what's the point of this other than
that that's why we call you the great
one Mark Levin thanks for being with us
don't forget life liberty lavin every
Sunday night 10:00 Eastern number one
show on that on cable that night don't
miss it